bueno presidente la república ha dicho
que el 70 por ciento de los crímenes que
se producen en el ecuador tienen una
relación directa con el dominio de las
cárceles ha dicho el ejecutivo no tiene
el dominio de las cárceles todavía ha
sido una afirmación emitida por el
propio presidente de la república cuando
se le preguntaba en el reciente
amotinamiento debes recordar que hace
muy poco se produjo un mayor
alzamiento por parte de los presos en
las cárceles y había dicho que esto
tiene relación específicamente porque el
ejecutivo no tiene el control total de
la cárcel debe también tomar en cuenta
de que el ecuador existen al menos
cuatro bandas en cuatro bandas
criminales que se disputan el dominio de
las cárceles territorios y de igual
forma también el narcotráfico del país
el ejecutivo nacional también ha dicho
que estas cuatro principales cárceles
están relacionadas con carteles
mexicanos de la droga y este dominio del
poder también se está llevando a las
calles ha dicho que el ejecutivo ha
reconocido que existe también un
hacinamiento superior al 60% en las
cárceles del país tanto como las
naciones unidas como el papá han pedido
atender al ejecutivo nacional la grave
situación carcelaria que existe en el
país esto ha producido también
reacciones por lo menos se ha propuesto
por parte de la alcaldesa de guayaquil
cynthia viteri proponer un proyecto de
ley para la libre de tenencia de armas y
de igual forma también ha habido
reacciones ya relacionadas con otros
temas en el ámbito legislativo es lo que
ocurre en este momento en ecuador